[Musica]
a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
supermario dopo anni che me lo stanno
chiedendo l'ho fatto l'ho fatto adesso
basta perché so che a voi piace vederli
molto tranquilla allora direi che
possiamo iniziare start del celle allora
ci sono dieci ribelli
vabbè iniziamo dall 1 raga non so se
riesco a binelli tu dici sull ora che
finalmente come si già dal ios di ier
ronchis to numeri o round ok ragazzi di
andare avanti così
e beh come che mario not everything is
what it seems ma non tutto è quello che
sembra sorretto anche il cazzo me ne
frega a me l'ho capito
ok ti piace scherzare allora vi può
piacere a me no invece alla ragazzi
vediamo di capirci un secondo quasi sono
due miliardi di trappole tra pro e ci
sono in un metro quadrato fatemi capire
c'è una buca li qui crolla tutto occhi
luca
ok non so che cosa ho fatto raga ma devo
andare di qua probabilmente best this
blog ragazzi c'è qualcosa che non quadra
non c'entra un cazzo tuo figlio sfogare
con qualcosa ma vabbè ragazzi qua c'è
qualcosa che non quadra perché non è
possibile che in due metri quadri ci
siano due miliardi truffle non è
possibile come ho fatto a farlo senza
vedere adesso non lo so neanch'io supera
questi blocchi passando da sotto o
ragazzi io c'ho paura fango veramente
paura di non fidarmi del gioco
va bene mi fido o stampe sapevo lo
sapevo
devo dire che ho fatto il figlio ne sono
paesi stanno ci stanno godendo lo so non
sapevo
l'avevo detto ceco i ragazzi sentito il
secondo ma è normale
no non lo russo scherza è normale che ci
siano tutte ste trappole sì sì sì sì
check point allora adesso in avanti se
muoio tipo adesso dovrei di partire di
qui
perfetto allora raga io non so se è
normale che sia morto 75 volte siamo
siamo all'inizio non è possibile non ci
posso credere non ci credo
ragazzi che sapevo fare crolla tutto
tutto ok ok questo non col non me ne ero
accorto adesso devo per forza saltarla
dall'altra parte non posso fare altro no
no no ragazzi non si può fare
impossibile sto gioco e pietro no no no
io avevo fatto più di tre metri senza
morire era un record bull renault
ragazzi dopo atene record già posso fare
non ce la posso fare il bisognino dire
che che mimì doman forte da solo tanto
crepa ragazzi non è possibile semplici
muoio su questo non ci sono le spine me
lo puoi buttare perché non mai preso
dov'era la roba dov'era dov'ero dov'era
sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
poi c'è la vj set famigie fa un cazzo
ragazzi sto gioca infattibile non posso
farle imposte vinto o vittora mente
[Musica]
ragazzi ho vissuto non ci posso credere
mancano soltanto 12 miliardi di altri
livelli
pensavate fosse finito verranno tanto lo
so che non sapevate
abbiamo altri due miliardi di livelli
con i quali divertirci insieme ragazzi
cos'è don't follow him non caderci
dentro e io ci vado invece perché prima
mi mentite allora sei proprio stronzo di
merda e con un passato di sotto posso di
nuovo lì sotto perché se non mi fossi lo
so ragazzi c'è una roccia io ci ho paura
a saltare di qua c'è un paura ma lo
faccio lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo lo
sapevo
la cosa veramente divertente ragazzi che
io l'espressò le trappole perché me lo
immagino come questa ma ciccato lo
stesso stai buona stai buona nota chi
stare calma porca [ __ ] telo anche
chiesto per favore ragazzi mai fidarsi
delle rocce che questo ti serva da
lezione perché le rocce non sono
affidabili e neanche il pavimento cioè
io stento a crederci che non sia
continuando a morire nello stesso
fottutissimo punto di merda è partito la
sente buona la sente buona ancora lui
ancora lui ancora lui
sì
ragazzi è stato l'azione più epica di
sempre l'intento mi prende di fare ste
cose non si sa perché facciamo finta di
niente ok e siamo tutti contenti
tranquilli porca [ __ ]
olè olè ha capito tutto ha capito una
mazza di minchia ragazzi ce la stiamo
facendo
ho paura a fare un passo avanti ho paura
non sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
tanto rara carrara santana carrara e
attacca la taranta tanta
quindi ragazzi devo dedurre che sia
questa perché l'altra non funzionava
bene non c'è una volta che ci azzecco
quando ci sono le scelte perfetto allora
devo andare di qua e adesso di nuovo
questo sono sicuro sì sì stavolta mi ha
[ __ ] non ha [ __ ] c'è la fine del
livello il primo pezzo dove c'è la
bandiera cade quindi devo andare in
questo davanti con soste ragione però vi
prego imposizioni ragazzi non ci credi
una volta che ci azzecco mio zio secondo
livello quando non mi ha [ __ ]
bastardo
lo sapevo ragazzi era era una trappola
ma stavolta l'ho girata laica pac in box
terzo livello perché noi siamo dei pro
della madonna e quindi riusciamo non
riusciamo a fare un cazzo ma noi ci
proviamo lo stesso not everything sims è
spuntato accumulando non si sa come va
va bene così reggente vieni a me vedo le
trappole ragazze voi non le vedete ma io
le sto vedendo tutte quella non l'avevo
vista però adesso non so adesso lo so
adesso lo so
[Musica]
check point non ci posso credere posso
fare già potere nel posso fare già posso
fare non ce la posso fare
ragazzi insomma arrivarci prova a fare
un salto incredibile
dio mio
e stata la cosa impressionante lega e
aic il cesio capiamoci un attimo con
tutto il casino che ho appena passato tu
mi dovresti far paura c'è ma mi odio lui
non sa ami solo di fronte su stronzo
cioè in pratica ragazzi deve evitare che
mi raggiunga una guai al running away
ragazze può fare il suo livello prima
che mi [ __ ] sapevo devo fare stowe
livello prima che mi raggiunga
impossibile ma ragazzi ve la cosa
simpatica che ti prendono anche bene
bene per il culo ma che c'è scritto why
are you running away perché stai
scappando via
ma perché c'è la tua sorella che mi sta
rincorrendo se no te ne fossi accorto
gli offre una volta qui faccio un salto
che va da fare invidia pura spider man
ok ok l'ho fatto effettivamente ha
funzionato pure c'è una no ma non è che
ci volete aggiungere per caso un qualche
aereo che mi cadde addosso non perché mi
sembra troppo facile non credete anche
voi perfetto tra tutti quelli che potevo
scegliere per perché qui perché questo
perché cosa più scuse che la mia mente
bacata tirato fuori per scegliere un per
mario cosa chi me l'ha consigliato di
viggiù ve l'ho detto prima vado a
controllare che stavano a controllare
chi è stato e lo vado a cercare io io se
sei tu hai mi hai consigliato che mario
tu proprio tu l'uno guardati bene le
spalle amico via perché ti giuro che sto
arrivando
voglio vedere chi ci azzecca se qualcuno
perde alla faccia vostra
sì sì sì sì sì sì checkpoint c'è poi la
vetta dove dov'è quel lurido no
ragazzi sto livello infattibile sentite
chiudo qui l'episodio perché in guarda
[Musica]